[Music]
now joe biden's border crisis is
worsening by the day frankly by the hour
and what we are seeing playing out on
the border is entirely self-inflicted
entirely a creation of biden's open
borders agenda
and amnesty agenda just look at this
we're now learning tonight that the
biden administration reportedly
has only expelled 13 percent of migrant
families in the last week
and according to axios that means that
just 13 percent of nearly 13 000 family
members
attempting to cross the u.s mexico
border
illegally will return to mexico between
march 14th
and march 21st and that's under title
42.
well that's open borders plain and
simple and of course biden the democrats
destructive agenda is on full display
all across the board as the biden team
is now plotting
to unveil yet another reckless spending
package
this one with a price tag get this 3
trillion
more dollars on top of the 2 trillion
they just spent
and that's expected to be packed with a
lot of green new deal climate measures
and that's not all because the efforts
could also to give d.c
statehood that appears to be gaining
some steam among democrats on capitol
hill
which again would be nothing more than a
blatant and shameless power grab to
stack the senate
with two more democratic senators here
with reaction all of this
and much more south carolina senator
lindsey graham
so let's get this straight they're not
following the laws
that your branch coequal branch of
government passed on immigration
now they want to bypass your branch as
it comes to the issue of of guns then
they want d.c statehood and puerto rico
statehood
because they think they'll that'll give
them four additional democratic senators
in perpetuity
and that means a majority in perpetuity
your reaction
yeah that well that's insane at multiple
levels but
congratulations to sarah carter and your
team
if this has proven to be true and i have
no doubt it is
we've got the video the humanitarian
yeah okay
all i can say is
well let me tell you this pod 3a
according to your reporting
is supposed to hold 80 people there were
694 children
in pod 3a being managed by two border
patrol agents
god bless the border patrol god bless
the
custom agents who are dealing with the
biden administration [ __ ] show
at the border i am going down with 18
senators friday
and if i'm denied the ability to look
into any place i want to go
we're going to shut the senate down
where all the liberal hypocrites where's
aoc
where's elizabeth warren where's vice
president harris
who basically protested outside of a
facility
in homestead florida during the trump
years holding migrant children
so here's my message president biden
vice president harris with all due
respect
get off your ass and go to the border
and look and see
what you have caused by policies that
will not work
quit denying the obvious this is not a
crisis
it's beyond a crisis it's a national
security
disaster in the making it's an inhumane
situation caused by bad policies
it will never change president biden
until you tell everybody to go home
and stop releasing people into the
united states if you're not willing to
do those two things
we'll have a million or two people at
our border by june
senator i wish i was wrong i predicted
that they in fact
would implement the most radical agenda
in history
i told you and yeah i told this audience
they would try to eliminate the
legislative filibuster
joe biden said he now supports that uh i
talked they
talked about they would try to pack the
courts they now have a commission
studying that very thing i mentioned d.c
puerto rico statehood
that is also happening i also predicted
they'd rule by executive fiat
they want open borders they want amnesty
so far i'm four for four
and five for five if you want to add
they destroy the energy sector
right well but let's not this is big
news can you imagine what would be
happening tomorrow morning
if you found these emails on president
trump's watch can you imagine the news
tomorrow
when you had 694 children in a
pod meant for 80 people managed by two
border patrol agents
can you imagine the problems with covid
that we're experiencing at the border
14 000 unaccompanied children a month
coming
why because the first thing they did is
decide to exempt unaccompanied children
from
title 42 deportation word spread all
over central america if a child makes it
into america
they're going to stay in america they're
not going to be sent back word is now
out all over central america the
remaining banks that go policy is being
abolished
if you get to america they're going to
release you in america they have created
this problem because they change
policies at working
where are the liberals going to the
border and and looking at the kids like
they did at trump
uh all i can say is i'm going down with
18 senators
if they deny me the ability to go where
i want to go and see what i want to see
we're going to shut the senate down okay
i'm not going to get away with this
you're going senator ted cruz is going
you're going this friday we'll be there
with you
and our cameras will be there and i i
want to ask you this
if you know i don't want to hear any
more lectures about mask wearing and
social distancing after looking at these
videos
you know over nearly 900 over capacity
here they're literally sleeping on top
of each other
and uh frankly those plastic containers
those
pods are the new kids in in cages and
maybe senator
you can please because i've asked and
i've been trying and we've had reporters
try
can you see if maybe you can get inside
the cargo shipping containers
that they're also dumping kids in the
ones with the tiny window with bars on
it
i'd like to see what those conditions
look like
i'd hate to be the guy that told me no
and it's not the border patrol agents
it's not the custom
agents they're doing a terrific job
under terrible circumstances
president biden needs to get to the
border along with his vice president
right now you need to go to the border
mr president
well you need to take you need to take a
good nap and get to the border
yeah well he's got to prepare most of
the week for his big press conference on
thursday
yes finally had one agenda item today
just one
one agenda item